domestic violence advocates are seeing
an influx of hotline calls an
international group has partnered with
local non-profits to teach more people
about the warning signs bianca holman
explains the resources available
back in
11 2011 ended up meeting somebody that i
thought was going to be my prince
charming and lo and behold about four
months into that relationship was the
first sign of physical violence michelle
gewsberry is a domestic violence
survivor it took her four years to leave
her abuser people had asked me many
times you know after that first sign of
physical violence or even the first sign
of emotional abuse why didn't you leave
and there is a cycle in domestic
violence a cycle of walking on eggshells
big blowups and then the apology stage
in order to help others jews berry
founded unsilenced voices the nonprofit
has hosted events in ghana sierra leone
dallas and now las vegas one in four
women in the u.s and one in seven to 11
men in the u.s experience domestic
violence
if you're trapped now is the time to get
out unsilenced voices has partnered with
groups like the shade tree and the
cupcake girls to educate the valley and
share resources for those experiencing
abuse your voice matters you matter and
it doesn't matter what he or she says to
you or about you
you can break free bianca holman live
local now
the unsilenced voices free domestic
violence community is monday may 23rd it
starts at 10 a.m at the blind center
lunch is also provided